in many ways he could consider Sherlock
Holmes to be one of the first
superheroes he was undoubtedly a key
inspiration in the creation of Batman's
character like Batman Sherlock Holmes
doesn't have any powers as such rather
he relies on his genius and his
intellect in the pursuit of justice also
like Batman Sherlock Holmes's abilities
are tantalisingly Within Reach
so the question is can you really think
like Sherlock Holmes Sherlock Holmes is
actually considered to be the most
portrayed character in film and TV with
over 254 incarnations over all that
media of course we've seen Sherlock
Holmes do all kinds of things some of
which quite fanciful and others of which
are quite grounded in reality
this must have registered on an
emotional first distract target so maybe
a good place to start would be to look
at John Watson's list of the things that
he's observed Sherlock Holmes to be
skilled in or adept at so here is
Watson's list of Sherlock Holmes's
skills and abilities knowledge of
literature nil knowledge of philosophy
nil knowledge of astronomy nil knowledge
of politics feeble knowledge of botany
variable well up in belladonna opium and
poisons generally knows nothing of
practical gardening knowledge of geology
practical but limited tells it to glance
different soils from each other after
walks has shown me splashes upon his
trousers and told me by their colour and
consistencies in what part of London he
had received them knowledge of chemistry
profound knowledge of anatomy accurate
but unsystematic knowledge of
sensational literature immense he
appears to know every detail of every
horror portrayed in the century plays
the violin well is an expert single
stick player boxer and swordsman has a
good practical knowledge of British law
so again like Batman Sherlock Holmes has
got a long list of different skills and
abilities more things than most of us
could learn to become that good at in a
single lifetime he does though focus on
specific areas that are useful for him
and clearly there's a lot of time
management going on here
things like politics just don't interest
him even though I would say that
probably
be useful for solving the crime but
that's beside the point I was admittedly
lost for a moment between chatting cross
and Hoban but I was saved by the bread
shop on saffron Hill the only Baker to
see a certain French glaze on their
lives they wish me sage so if we wanted
to learn this kind of range of and depth
of skills we might look at different
accelerated learning techniques who
might use something like the Fineman
technique for instance or Tim Ferriss is
dis method I've talked a little about
these in previous videos I'll talk about
them more on future but supposed to say
there are ways to obtain multiple skills
more quickly and ways to approach
learning and if you employ these you
certainly can speed up your skill and
knowledge acquisition likewise very
important is just to focus on learning
keep learning the more you learn the
more you read the better you become at
absorbing information again I've gone
over this on the channel before but it
boils down to brain plasticity this is
the ability of the brain to grow and
change shape and the more we learn the
more we read the more we produce
hormones and neurotransmitters like BDNF
brain-derived neurotrophic factor which
support the creation of new neural
connections so the more you learn the
better you are at learning and as you
stop experiencing new things your brain
kind of solidifies and eventually starts
to atrophy and that's one of the reasons
we start to see our cognitive powers
decline as we get older because we stop
learning new things so keep your brain
fresh keep reading keep challenging
yourself watch youtube videos on super
speed listen to all the ball whilst
you're cooking and washing up and use
accelerated learning techniques if that
interests you but of course the primary
skill that we associate with Sherlock
Holmes is his art of deduction and this
is his ability to observe somebody and
then know where they've been know who
they are
tell them all sorts of personal intimate
details about themselves and freak them
out based on the speck of dirt on their
collar and the tear at their ankle which
might tell them that they have a dog and
that they've been mud-wrestling recently
about them the sentimental widow and her
son
unemployed fishermen elseis yes yes it's
got a west highland terrier called
whisky lexically what we're looking for
sure because duction a real skill and
that's something that you can go about
developing yourself well the art or the
science of deduction as its referred to
in the books is something that was made
up by Arthur Conan Doyle it's not real
science that doesn't mean we can't learn
it doesn't mean it's not grounded in
some more realistic principles so the
first clue to successfully deducing
information from limited data is to
deduce so the clue is in the name
deduction subtraction rather than going
into a situation with a hypothesis with
a conclusion preformed try to remove all
of your preconceptions and prejudices
and instead just observe the situation
for what it is in the book of Master
Mind how to think like Sherlock Holmes
the author talks a lot about cognitive
biases and fallacies and how these can
upset our conclusions and cause us to
jump to the wrong ones you need to make
sure that you're looking for causation
or correlation not making assumption and
then eliminate what isn't the answer and
you should be left with what is a
Sherlock Holmes says once you eliminate
the impossible what you're left with no
matter how improbable must be the truth
so that's paraphrasing but the point is
that you're removing every wrong option
in order to be left eventually with the
right option now of course what's more
important is that you're able to observe
and if you're really going to be able to
spot that person on the street who has a
bit of flour on him that tells you he's
a baker you're going to need to keep
your eyes and ears open so again this is
something I've talked about in previous
videos on this channel this is such a
big topic that I'm going for breath
rather than depth and if you're
interested in learning more about any of
these things then I'll have links to my
other videos and articles down below so
being more observant this comes down to
mindfulness and meditation because so
many of us are in our own heads we're
constantly in our default mode networks
where daydreaming we're thinking about
all sorts of things worrying about work
being distracted by billboards and by
our phones buzzing in our pockets but
not just looking around and being open
to the new information that's available
to us so practice mindfulness by just
taking the time to engage with the world
around you next time you go for a walk
take the time to look around try and be
out of your own mind and instead feel
the wind on your skin hear the noises
and look for things in the environment
one game I like to play to try and
increase my observational skills is just
to set myself some kind of challenge
like I might look for everyone wearing a
tie and that just keeps my eyes open and
prevents them from being inside my own
head it's a good way of getting into
that positive habit but any form of
mindfulness training or meditation will
over time improve the ability to change
your focus from internal to external and
to be more aware of your senses and your
surroundings I also talked in a previous
video about splatter vision splatter
vision means engaging your peripheral
vision and when you engage your
peripheral vision you allow yourself to
absorb more information through your
senses and most you lose some detail you
increase the breath again breath over
depth that's like a theme of this video
so to engage your splatter vision or
your allies as it's also referred to you
put your arms out like this wiggle your
fingers and then observe your fingers
with the sides of your eyes with your
peripheral vision and then keep looking
forwards but just keep your vision wider
like this like I say you'll lose some of
the detail some of the focus that you
get from focusing on one point but
you're now taking in more information
and this is something that survivalists
will use when they're walking through
the wild and it's also something that
FBI agents are trained when observing
crowds for suspicious behavior splatter
vision and mindfulness are just two ways
to increase your situational awareness
situational awareness simply means being
more aware of your surroundings on
what's going on and this is once again
something that is trained in FBI agents
and mi5 but it's also generally useful
and could help you to survive best if
there's some kind of crisis its react
quickly to a problem one way you can
improve your situational awareness is to
establish it a baseline that means
establishing the mood of the room or the
area and working out what normal
behavior in that situation is and once
you've established is based on then you
can look for people who are acting and
usually anomalies and they will stand
out to you more
likewise you also need to make sure you
have a good view of your surroundings
that might just mean situation yourself
in the corner of the room so your backs
to the wall nor can sneak up behind you
and you can get a good overall view of
your surroundings look out for key sites
such as exits or potential weapons or
people that look like they might start
trouble you can find an excellent
article on situational awareness over at
the Art of Manliness I'll leave a link
to that in the description down below I
recommend you check it out I come in
here and the first thing I'm doing is
I'm catching the sight lines I'm looking
for an exit I see the exit sign - I'm
not worried I can tell you the
license-plate numbers of our six cars
outside we can do all this you can be
more mindful if you can use your
splatter vision if you can practice
techniques and read about a situational
awareness then all of this will help you
to increase your observational skills so
that you can start to make more
deductions one last thing that might be
useful for you to learn as well as body
language and body language is a very
interesting topic and something I might
cover more on this channel in future but
basically it means looking at different
aspects of the way someone's standing or
the way they're moving and even what
they're wearing etc and how they're
positioning themselves in relation to
other people and then estimating how
they must be feeling what they're
thinking and what they're planning and
that's another aspect of course it's
very useful if you're going to learn
more about a person or a situation
that's of course only one part of making
a deduction because that gives you the
information you're absorbing more
information from the world around you
but the deduction itself means finding
patterns and connections from that
information and from your environment so
how can you make more of these
connections well again I've talked about
this in previous videos but it comes
down to increasing your creativity so
how can we be more creative and get
better at problem solving so that we can
provide more novel hypotheses and
conclusions well often this comes down
to relaxing and allowing our brain to
explore the myriad ideas when we're very
focused or very stressed we tend to
focus on just one idea or one subject we
might be worried about work or might be
distracted by that shifty looking guy in
the corner but when we relax when we
allow our brain to explore different
ideas this is when we can come up with
novel
because we're looking at different parts
of our brain at once we might be
daydreaming whilst also kind of looking
over there knowing what I think hang on
those two things are related so we're
looking at the Bank of information and
the stimulus in front of us and we're
combining those things in order to come
up with a novel idea so you need to be
more relaxing you to train yourself to
stay relaxed in a high tense situation
at the same time you can also check out
my video on functional fixedness and how
you can use different techniques in
order to overcome the tendency to view
things in a very set and confined way
and of course in the books and many of
the TV shows and films
Sherlock Holmes will also experiment
with drugs in order to increase his
creativity now of course I'm not going
to recommend that you start doing some
kind of hard Class A drugs in order to
think more like Sherlock Holmes that's
more likely to make you think like a
vegetable so what I would recommend
instead is just to take time out and
meditate much healthier much safer way
to increase your relaxation and to
explore different ideas and maybe
consider experimenting little with
nootropics you could try l-theanine this
relaxes the brain and like I say that's
up to you again I've got content on the
site about that if that's something that
interests you so now we're more
observant and also more creative the
next step is to try and increase the
amount of information available to us
because as we've seen Sherlock Holmes
has got a lot of information about a lot
of different topics like I said you can
use accelerated learning techniques to
increase your knowledge in different
fields but at the same time he seems to
have an incredible memory and this is
something that's often played up in the
shows and on TV and in the books so how
can you increase your ability to store
potentially useful information and then
use that to make assumptions about the
world going forwards well now we're
getting into the realm of memory master
techniques and that's something I
haven't touched on on this site much but
I definitely will be in future so if you
want to see more about memory master
techniques and subscribe but generally
increasing your ability to remember
something ultimately comes down to
making it more memorable that sounds
obvious but it's often eludes us so when
you try and remember a number
the problem with remembering a number or
the name of some researcher that you've
got to remember for your course the
problem with that is that it's just very
dull it has no personal meaning to you
no context it's just this dull random
word or number and to your brain to your
primal brain there's nothing
particularly interesting about that
there's no reason to store that
information so how might we make this
more interesting well one option is to
use mnemonics and that simply means that
you're using a rhyme or some kind of
memorable phrase or you're linking that
idea to another idea in your brain or
creating an image around that idea and
by doing this you're just linking
something boring to something much more
interesting that works for your brain
and the way that you store information
but there's way more interesting and
advanced techniques you can use as well
one of the best resources for this is
Darren Browns trick of the mind now on
biohacking and brain training videos
like this I rarely hear Darren Brown
mentioned but that's a shame because
Darren Brown is awesome if anyone is a
real-life Sherlock Holmes it's probably
Darren brown and I'm lucky enough to
have briefly met him in real life and
he's also a really sound guy so yeah
he's a legend and again I might do more
on Darren Brown in future yeah all right
look at me look at me first thing is you
walk towards me your posture is strong
and solid there's obviously a physical
and control thing that you're involved
in your handshake was solid there's a
kind of a thing you're kind of checking
me out almost not suspicious but you're
checking me out so I'm guessing
securities regulation haircuts we're not
about so this is maybe something to do
with police so in the book trick of the
mind Aaron Brown talks about many of the
techniques he uses that includes things
like misdirection but also of course
memory master techniques and he goes up
a lot of more interesting and more
advanced techniques such as the linking
method and here you've got a long list
of objects you need to remember and you
associate each one with a ridiculous or
particularly memorable image and then
you link that image to the next item on
the list the image that you associate
with that item so by linking them you
create a sequence and you can
regurgitate that list in the exact order
for ages I went through the exercise in
the book and I can remember this list of
objects for months and months afterwards
it's very effective he also talks about
the loci methods associated with the
ancient Greek art of memory and this
basically means that you're associating
images with items you need to remember
usually on a route that you know well
like your route home so you might
picture item one
beyond the corner of the road you might
picture items to to be at that tree that
you pass on the way home and by doing
this you can visualize going through
that walk and thereby see each of the
items on your list using your mind's eye
and of course the next step from that is
to use a memory palace and this is what
we see a lot in the show Sherlock pretty
technique sort of mental map you plot a
map where the location doesn't have to
be a real place of any deposit memories
there this is basically either a real
place or an imagined place that you
visualize in your mind's eye and
position things you want to remember
around to that palace and by linking
these dull difficult obtuse facts and
figures to things you know well in your
environment or your imagined environment
you can thereby explore them in your
mind's eye and remember these things
much more effectively the memory palace
technique is a fascinating one and again
something I'll be talking about more on
this channel in future and one last one
that Darren brown goes over is the peg
system this is more for numbers and of
course numbers are difficult to remember
because they're very dull very bland so
instead of remembering one two three you
might remember bun loo C and then
picture those things and picturing those
things combining those items in two
interesting scenes in your mind's eye
can help you to remember what otherwise
a dull number so basically what you're
doing with all of these techniques is
taking something dull or obtuse or
arbitrary and then linking it with
something that's more memorable more
emotive in your mind's eye in order to
retrieve it more easily in future so it
boils down to Association and another
interesting example of using Association
to remember things better is synesthesia
so synesthesia is a phenomenon affecting
some people usually by birth and it
basically means that they associate one
sense with activation in another so if
you were to see numbers you might find
that you experience them in different
colors or if you listen to music you
might find that you notice different
colors floating around you or you might
find that when you see certain letters
you imagine them to have some kind of
personality this is since easier because
you've got crosstalk between the
different perceptions
in the brain but it can take a range of
different forms and in some cases it can
actually be quite beneficial like a
superpower for the individual so in one
case Daniel Tammet who is a famous
mathematician is able to visualize
numbers as objects as quantities and by
doing this he was able to recite PI and
break the European record I kept a list
of words according to their shape and
texture words round as a three goggle
cupboard cabbage another example that I
read about recently was someone who
observed scary scenes when they were
feeling scared so if they were feeling
uncomfortable or anxious about something
then they would witness a kind of scenic
view of hills and mountains that set
them slightly on edge and this turned
out to be useful for them because they
once were approaching a snake and
apparently they weren't consciously
aware of the snake but obviously they
were unconsciously aware of it this
flashed up this view of mountains
looking scary and actually alerted them
to the presence of the snake before they
became consciously aware of it so they
stopped walking was I think they're on a
bike we stopped their bike and they
didn't hit the snake and they averted
danger there's almost like a spider
sense that's created through syntheses
ear some other people see grids in their
vision when they're using synesthesia so
it has real application and a lot of
people say it helps their memory that's
why I hypothesized that were Sherlock
Holmes are real then he might actually
have some kind of form of synesthesia
the terms in the seizure itself might
actually be somewhat inaccurate more
recently it's being referred to as
ideasthesia seeing as it's not so much
to do with your senses as it is to do
with concepts so if you were paying
attention when I said that seeing
numbers or letters could make you feel a
certain way while seeing letters and
numbers isn't vision vision is vision
seeing letters and numbers is more to do
with the semantics the meaning of what
you're seeing and this is what causes
you to experience the numbers or the
colors likewise with music it's the fact
that it's music norther it's sound that
makes you see those things and numbers
and seeing mathematical grids is another
example of this so it might be more to
do with ideas rather than
census it's also useful to note there
are two different types of synesthesia
or ideasthesia these are projective and
associative so projective is when you
actually literally see the color or the
environment or the grid
whereas associative is where you just
kind of feel or know that Association
what's really interesting is you might
be able to develop associative since
this year through training several
studies have found this now they
generally involve getting something to
read a book and that book will have a
certain letter and certain color
eventually that letter is missing and
you just see the color and then this
replaces lots of letters and eventually
just seeing that colors is enough to
help you read and there are other
examples of how you can train
synesthesia in this way I'm really
interested in the use of the abacus so
an abacus of course is the thing you use
to do maths when you're younger and you
slide the pegs along the rails and
eventually this can actually improve
your maths because you can visualize
that abacus and use it to perform sums
and there are different tools like this
that allow you to do more complex
mathematics and this is a very good way
to perform nearly as well as a
calculator without the calculator and
this is very similar to what we saw in
Daniel Tammet or someone who visualizes
a grid when they do maths because you're
using a different sense to help you
tackle a different subject and you're
doing that through Association trained
Association since these are actually
seems to occur in all of us to some
extent it's a large part of how language
develops so it makes sense that you
should be able to develop this and it
might also be that by increasing certain
new transmitters you can develop
synesthesia occasionally an injury can
bring on synesthesia and this needs to
be because it causes a sudden release of
huge amounts of neurotransmitters and
using certain drugs has also been shown
to bring on synesthesia like experiences
so maybe nootropics could have a role
here as well or just trying to increase
your brain plasticity in order to make
your brain more malleable so that not
only will you be able to retain more
information that you might also be able
to develop more learning techniques and
even trained synesthesia finally
Sherlock Holmes also has a very
impressive working memory this is the
memory that we use to hold on to ideas
whilst we manipulate them so if you're
doing some working memory is what you
use in order to carry numbers over in
your mind's eye working memory it seems
is actually synonymous
with visualization is the ability to
visualize a number or sound or an object
or a room so that you can work on that
idea without actually having to have it
written down in front of you so
visualization and training visualization
will improve your working memory so too
will brain training games like the dual
n-back test and likewise they will chess
and of course chess is something that we
often see Sherlock Holmes playing in the
various films and TV series I did a
video on working memory so if you want
to learn more about that then that's
another one to check out it will be
linked in the description down below
also and improving your working memory
like this can also help to perform that
awesome feat that Sherlock Holmes
performs at the end of the second Robert
Downey jr. film where he plays that game
of chess against Moriarty just by words
because he's able to visualize the
entire chessboard and where all the
pieces are at the same time Bishop to
Bishop 7 Queen takes Knight pawn does
the art of domestic horticulture
this is also how he's able to do that
kind of shark Holmes vision fighting
where he predicts the outcome of the
fight if he does this or that this would
be based again on working memory the
ability to store information and
visualize it but also on his theory of
mind his ability to predict how others
will behave which you can get and
develop through observation which we've
said is very important I'd also
recommend just spending time people
watching it's a great skill for
developing your body language skills and
your general observation and by training
that internal physics engine which I've
talked about in previous videos on
visualization training so that's a whole
lot of cover just there like I say Rhett
not depth but basically you can improve
your ability to think like Sherlock
Holmes by learning more using
accelerated learning techniques by
improving your memory by using memory
mass and techniques by training your
visualisation and your working memory by
reading as much as possible by observing
people by people watching by learning
about body language and all those things
and improving your nutrition and your
exercising your sleep to make your brain
as plastic as possible and keep it
growing so can you think like Sherlock
Holmes probably not exactly like the
character in the books but certainly you
can think a little bit more like him
with the right training and with the
right input
hope you found this video useful
interesting guys if you did then please
consider leaving a like please share it
around that helps me so much check out
my social media channels down below I'm
on Instagram Twitter Facebook that's
where I post my workouts and my training
and my working online and if you're
interested in this topic and others like
it then please subscribe to the channel
I've got much more coming on brain
training bodybuilding fitness running
parkour working online nootropics
nutrition you name it so if that sounds
good
then thanks a ton for watching and I'll
see you next time bye for now